these days billionaire Elon Musk does much of
his communication through Twitter the company
he now owns on Friday musk appeared in court on
the witness stand in a trial over tweets that
may have crashed the stock price of Tesla another
musk company leaving shareholders holding the bag
from San Francisco of correspondent
John Blackstone has this story
as a CEO with Rockstar status a builder
of electric cars and Rockets and now the
controversial owner of Twitter Elon Musk is a
hero to some and a villain to others but it was
as a defendant that he testified Friday in federal
court in San Francisco where he told the jury just
because I tweet something does not mean people
believe it or act accordingly musk is being sued
by Tesla investors who say they lost billions when
in August 2018 he tweeted and considering taking
Tesla private at 420 dollars funding secured
Mark fagal is a retired Securities litigator
this is an unusually straightforward case you have
a couple of tweets that are as close to black and
white as you as you can get did he in fact have
funding secured or not so it's much simpler than
the typical Securities fraud case the investor
lawsuit claims musk never did have funding secure
wood and the lawsuit suggests musk set the price
as part of a joke claiming musk grounded the
price up to 420 per share because he thought his
girlfriend at the time the singer known as Grimes
would find it funny due to the significance of
the number to marijuana users 420 is a code for
marijuana could he say I was a joke they shouldn't
have taken it seriously they should know that I
that I'm not Dependable when I'm tweeting I think
the flaw in that argument is it did drive the
price way up so clearly it appears that investors
did take it seriously one of those investors was
Glenn Littleton the first witness in the case who
testified musk's tweets cost him more than three
million dollars as Tesla's share price soared
and then dropped as it became evident that musk
did not have funding to take the company private
in his opening statement Tesla's attorney said
musk had simply used the wrong words in his tweet
interestingly his defenses pretty limited because
the court has already ruled as a matter of law
that the tweets were misleading so he can't come
in and say in fact I did have the money available
to take the company private so if he doesn't have
the ability to say these tweets weren't fraudulent
it really leaves intent I didn't intend to mislead
the market and he can also argue that really
this didn't impact buyers you know investors
were Investing For Myriad other reasons and
it wasn't my tweet that caused them to lose
money what are the risks for human testifying
well ultimately this is going to come down to
credibility so like I said we already know from
the court that this tweet is misleading it's
really what was his intent behind it it will be up
to the nine members of the jury to decide how much
investors were harmed in the 10 days after the
Tweet so as a technical legal matter if you bought
during that period the damages are calculated
by what happened after you bought when the truth
was revealed and when the truth here was revealed
that in fact he was not going to take the company
private and the stock collapsed that should
really be the cutoff date people were harmed
as of that date but as more and more cars rolled
off the Tesla assembly line over the next years
the stock backing up the successful car company
remained volatile even hitting historic highs
that can now complicate the legal dispute over
losses the big issue is how much were investor
losses and if you look at a longer term Tesla's
stock price skyrocketed in the months and years
after these tweets so you could say well
people who were misled by these tweets and
decided to buy Tesla stock ended up doing okay
as a result mosque and Tesla have already paid
40 million dollars to the Securities and Exchange
Commission to settle fraud charges over the tweet
this case could cost musk Millions more musk
has a lot of money though he can afford to pay
his lawyers to take it to trial he can afford
to pay damages most companies and individuals
the potential Stakes are so high the amount of
investor losses are so high that if you roll the
dice of trial and lose that's going to put your
company out of business he is the second richest
man in the world he can afford to pay damages
so he's taking a chance not long ago he was the
richest man in the world thanks to tweeting musk
testified for less than a half hour Friday he's
expected to return to the stand Monday for CBS
Saturday morning John Blackstone San Francisco
interesting on his face as he said what a simple
case a transparent case it is he said this it's
right there right another question is what was the
intent and what was he thinking and then it's also
I feel like the good and the bad of Twitter all
in one yep pretty much yeah anything goes I guess